The other interesting thing is things fall down in the interesting fashion
as you deviate from 10, 11, 12, 13, 14 all the way to 0 or 20.
Obviously we got a curve that looks a bit like this.
This curves is often called a bell curve because it's quite feasible to think of it as a church bell--
that's move left and right and rings the bells.
I did a related experiment--actually I bought a piece of software to flip a coin 1000 times
and if you did the last optional units on programming, you wrote a piece of software
to flip a coin a 1000 times and from that, I looked at the empirical frequency
which is the same as that count of heads divided by a 1000, but this one scales between 0 and 1.
I called this thing an experiment--I flip the coin a 1000 times, out comes a one singular number
which is the ratio of heads to the total number of experiments.
It should be 0.5 in the ideal case but often it's a little bit off 0.5.
I repeated this experiment 1000 times and that means
I've got 1000 samples of this ratio over here. When I do this, I got a whole bunch of means.
When I run a histogram over those, I might see a curve.
What shape do you think the curve has--is it going to be like this, is it going to be like this,
like this or like this, all are focused on 0.5.
Which one do you think is it?